Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Tonight,
Silicon Valley veteran
and self‐made
billionaire investor Chris Sacca
returns to the Tank.
Coding is a golden ticket
to a great job.
Look, I'm intrigued.
It's a company I can believe in.
Are you making
any money yet?
$10 million in sales.
[ Laughs ]
I'm gonna
make you an offer.
Feel free to be a savage
on equity.
Narrator: This is
the art of doing business.
I love what you're doing.
The goal is phenomenal.
If Mark had a new idea,
it would die of loneliness.
[ Laughs ]
I don't see what
he brings to the table.
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
Herjavec:
Never build the strategy
on the stupidity
of your competitors.
Bozos.
♪♪
My name is Gauri Nanda
and I'm from New York City.
My parents came from India
and immigrated
to the United States
with just $10 in their pockets.
They tried their hands
at several businesses,
eventually taking over
a failing newspaper,
and they built it up to success
and ended up selling it
for a profit in 2007.
I went to MIT for grad school,
and it was there that I created
a product for a class project,
and it became a runaway success.
Voice box:
Hold on! I'm thinking!
Nanda: I spent many years
building that company,
but eventually I wanted to do
something
a little bit more meaningful,
and that's when I started
my new company.
You guys are
our first product testers.
10 years ago,
I created a product
that went viral overnight.
Now, that doesn't happen twice
very often.
These are the thoughts
that keep me up at night,
and I wonder
if I can do it again.
I followed
in my parents' footsteps
and became an entrepreneur
myself.
I admire their story, and now
I want them to see me succeed.
This is an entirely new market
we're trying to create,
and if I don't get a deal
from the Sharks,
it'll be very difficult
to make that happen.
♪♪
Hi, guys.
My name is Gauri Nanda,
and this is my friend Ellie,
who's gonna
be helping me out today.
I am the co‐founder of Toymail
out of New York City,
and I'm seeking $250,000
for 2.5% of my company.
Whew.
Sharks, Toymail is all about
bringing families together,
especially when they're apart.
We want
to connect parents to kids
in the simplest way possible.
And we're not doing it
by giving your kids a phone.
We're doing it with the talkies.
Now, with the talkies,
kids as young as 3 can,
for the first time in their
lives, send a voice message,
and they don't need a phone.
They just push a button
on the back of their toy,
and that message is
immediately sent to a loved one.
Hi, Dad.
Mr. Wonderful
says it's fine
if I stay up all night
watching "Shark Tank" reruns.
Love you.
Bye.
[ Laughs ]
That message goes
to parent‐approved contacts.
So, parents can listen
to that message
directly with the Toymail app.
Ellie: Hi, Dad.
Mr. Wonderful says it's fine
if I stay up all night
watching "Shark Tank" reruns.
Love you.
Bye.
Nanda: And they can
use the app to respond,
so Ellie's dad might say,
"Tell Mr. Wonderful that
vampires don't need sleep,
but Ellie does."
Toy: Tell Mr. Wonderful that
vampires may not need sleep,
but Ellie does.
[ Chuckles ]
Our hardware
is completely interchangeable.
That means you can pop it out
and put it
into a new animal skin
as your child's
interests change.
Wow.
Talkies also respond
to physical play.
[ Toy giggles ]
[ Chuckles ]
Talkies
are completely expandable.
That means parents
can unlock new features,
educational content,
or games or stories or songs.
Sharks, I hope you'll join us in
connecting families everywhere.
And, Ellie, if you would please
pass out some sharks
for our Sharks.
♪♪
Hey, Ellie, thanks.
Yep.
Toy:
Message from Lori the Shark.
[ Giggles ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Toys giggling ]
I love the laugh.
It's really cute.
O'Leary: So, does this use
the home's wireless
to actually communicate
with the app?
How come mine's
still talking?
Exactly.
So, it's all WiFi‐based.
That means that you don't
have to have a phone
or a laptop nearby
to use it.
And parents don't want
to put their kids...
Toy: Hey!
...in front
of another screen.
It's a huge struggle
for them.
Hey!
Security's a concern.
It's obviously
not child‐proof,
because Lori is
driving me nuts over there.
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary: Okay.
Continue.
So, Verizon is actually
one of our investors.
And they don't have a device
to sell kids under 10.
This is a huge untapped market
for that segment.
Another one of our opportunities
is with Amazon,
so Amazon is a big investor
in our company.
Amazon actually ‐‐
they were very interested
in working with us
to bring their
Echo voice‐control
technology to our toys.
And what that means is that
every single one of our toys
is going to turn
into an Echo machine for kids.
Herjavec: So how much
have you raised?
They gave us
half a million dollars.
At what valuation
did they do that?
At a $10 million cap.
How much money
have you raised total?
So, we have raised to date
$1.6 million...
Ooh.
...on that $10 million cap.
All in that
$10 million cap?
Yes.
That's a really
high price
for your very first
round of financing.
What will this
retail for?
So, we're doing it
at a retail of $50 MSRP.
What does it cost you
to manufacture it?
So, our cost of goods
is $20,
so it's great margins
for e‐commerce retail.
We'll be ‐‐ actually be bringing
down those costs of goods.
That's not gonna work
in retail.
So, yes, we'll be bringing down
our cost of goods,
it looks like $10
in the next year as we scale.
What's your background?
I have kind of
a unique background.
10 years ago,
I was a student at MIT.
And I could never get myself
out of bed in the morning,
so what I did
is I created this alarm clock,
this funny little thing
called Clocky
that would jump off
your nightstand
and then run around your room,
kind of forcing you
out of bed in the morning.
[ Laughter ]
So, that product
went viral.
I was able to bootstrap it
to $10 million in sales.
[ Laughs ]
Is it part
of this deal?
No, Toymail
is a separate entity.
Good for you.
But we believe Toymail
is way bigger.
Gauri,
you're the real deal.
I mean,
very impressive.
Here's my challenge
with it.
You're willing
to sell 2.5%.
It's too small
an equity stake for me.
I ‐‐ I'm not
interested in that.
I wish you the best.
I'm out.
So, when you made
your presentation
or your discussions
with Verizon and Amazon,
what did you project out
three years and five years
from now, top line?
So, next year, we project to do
over $2.5 million in sales.
From there, we're scaling up
to $12 million in sales.
Could you see this being
a $100 million revenue company?
That's absolutely
the way we look at this.
O'Leary:
So, look, having seen dozens
of iterations of plush toys,
I'm impressed.
I really am.
But it leaves nothing.
I mean, I would need
five Clockys
to get out of bed
for 2.5%.
[ Laughs ]
I got ‐‐ it's just ‐‐ it
doesn't even get me interested.
I'm out.
Look, I like just about
everything about this business.
You made $10 million
from your dorm room.
I think you're uniquely
qualified to take this on.
The part I don't like about it
is this valuation.
I think for something this early
without a ton of sales yet,
it's hard right off the bat
to come out at 10 million bucks.
And so, with all that said,
I do want to make you an offer.
Okay.
I want to give you $400,000
for 5% of the company.
Um, that's
a very generous offer.
Thank you, Chris.
It's definitely an offer
I'd love to consider.
Of course,
I want to get the best offer
for ‐‐ for my company.
Well, look,
I'm very confident
in my offer,
so I invite you
to shop mine around,
'cause I know
it's gonna hold out.
Maybe not.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Gauri has one offer on the table
from Chris Sacca for Toymail,
a toy enabling kids
to send and receive voicemails.
But Mark Cuban
may be interested.
So, what I'll do is
I'll offer you $500,000 for 5%,
but I'd like to ask
for some real estate,
because I don't have
a specific need right now,
but at some point
over the next couple years,
if there's
children's content
or relevant content
that I come through,
because I have over
a billion dollars
in content assets ‐‐
whether it's movies, teams,
whatever it may be.
Mm‐hmm.
There's a significant value
there.
That's ‐‐ That's
wonderful.
I mean, we would love
to have your expertise
as well as, of course,
your content would be amazing
to build up this platform.
Gauri, let me ‐‐
Is that a yes, Gauri?
Two offers,
you've got two offers.
Gauri, is that a yes?
And then there's me.
‐I‐I‐I...
‐Let's talk.
‐Wait!
‐Wait a minute.
There's still me.
[ Nanda chuckles ]
I do want to have ‐‐
let Lori speak,
but that's
a very generous offer.
Thank you.
I'm sure you came in here
with thoughts
of what different Sharks
could do for you.
Lori, you've made
tons of investments
in hardware companies,
and I know you're instrumental
with distribution.
How can I do something
where it's not gonna
take me forever and
ever and ever and ever
to see
the fruits of my labors?
What would you say to me
is a deal
that you think
we together...
Mm‐hmm.
...could be
excited about?
You want her
to make you an offer?
‐Yeah, I do.
‐Wow.
I want to hear
what she would say,
'cause she has two ‐‐
Negotiate
against yourself.
Um...
Gauri, did Mark not offer you
the exact same?
And I'm not gonna stay here
forever, Gauri.
I really appreciate Mark's deal,
and, of course, if you want ‐‐
you know, if you could come in
with Mark on that deal,
of course two Sharks
are better than one.
Here's what
I would say.
Um...
Is I do actually think
Lori has a unique skill set
for a deal like this.
Right.
And I do have
a lot of respect
for her deep understanding
of marketing.
Mark, on the other hand,
if he had a new idea,
it would die
of loneliness.
And so I don't see what
he brings to the table.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, whatever.
So here's what
I would like to propose.
I would give you 600K
for 5% of the company,
as well as the option to put up
to an additional million dollars
in the next round.
Just increased your value
by 20%.
You're up
to $12 million now.
I did. I did.
Lori is invited to come in
and take any part of that deal
that she wants to take,
large or small.
But what percentage
would I get?
You can put in any fraction
of the $600,000
and get the related percentage
of the company...
At the same value
of $12 million.
... at the same value
that I'm paying.
And she probably wants
two Sharks over one.
And so if you wanted to come in
at 300K and split it with me,
you'd get 2.5%
of the company.
What if I put in $200,000
for the 2.5%?
No, no, you and I aren't gonna
pay different prices, Lori.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah.
Basically,
it devalues me.
You would end up getting
a cheaper price than I do.
Well, because I'm gonna be
a workhorse out there.
Are you willing to take the deal
Chris has on the table
without Lori?
I am willing to do that deal.
You don't have
a choice, Lori.
She's gonna do the deal alone
with Chris.
All right.
I'll go in with Chris.
Lori, I ‐‐
For how much?
I'll do it for $300,000
for 2.5%.
We got a deal?
We've got a deal.
‐Right on.
‐Thank you, guys.
Okay.
Congratulations.
Great. Really wanted
to do a deal with you.
You did it smart.
Oh, thank you.
Whoo!
Thank you guys so much.
‐Yeah, nice job.
Thank you.
Congrats, Gauri.
♪♪
This really went better
than ‐‐ than I could
have even dreamed.
Chris and Lori
bring to the table
an amazing combination.
Chris is strong on the hardware
and the Internet side,
and Lori is great
with distribution,
so it's a perfect partnership of
two very different skill sets.
What was your line
about Mark?
Lori,
I don't think this ‐‐
If Mark had a new idea,
it would die of loneliness.
[ Laughter ]
Only 'cause I know better
and I can laugh at it.
Ohh!
Narrator: In season 7,
Konel Banner and Frank Weston
landed a deal with
Lori Greiner and Mark Cuban
for their fire starter
InstaFire.
What if Mark and I
went to 30%?
You got a deal.
‐Yeah.
‐Whoo!
Business
has been on fire
since we made a deal
with Mark and Lori.
Weston: We're now
in Home Depot, Target,
and we're gonna be
in 7,000 retail locations
and 2,800 Walmarts.
The year before "Shark Tank,"
we did $378,000 in sales.
Since making the deal
on "Shark Tank,"
we've done $2.4 million.
Our newest product
is a solid fuel tablet
that's gonna be used
in conjunction with our stove.
And the stove can be used for
camping, emergency‐preparedness,
making food preparation
a breeze.
Konel, Frank!
‐Hey!
‐Hi!
Today, Lori's coming
to check out our new product
and meet the president
of KMG International,
a company
that specializes
in green energy
in developing countries.
We're involved in
another project, called iCabin,
where we bring electricity to
villages that are off the grid.
I want each iCabin
to be a distribution
point for InstaFire.
I'm very happy today
to issue you
your first PO from KMG
for 2.1 million pucks.
‐Oh, my God!
‐For $400,000 U. S.
Greiner: I have sat
in a lot of meetings.
I don't think
there's ever been a time
where somebody has ordered
2.1 million of something
just like that.
To be able to help people
that have to walk
for miles a day
just to get a fuel starter,
this is gonna revolutionize
their lives.
And it's gonna help
the world be greener.
Thank you.
Weston:
The "Shark Tank" experience
has been one
of the greatest experiences
that we could ever have.
This is the American dream
coming true in Clearfield, Utah.
We started out
as a small, little company,
and now look at us.
We're a global,
international company.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a foolproof way
to have a green thumb.
Hi, my name's Ryan Woltz.
I'm from Denver, Colorado.
I'm the founder of Edn,
and I'm seeking $150,000
for a 10% stake in my company.
At Edn, we're on a mission to
paint the concrete jungle green
and to change the way
the world grows plants.
Growing is hard.
It requires time, expertise,
and attention.
And even if
you do everything right,
you can still kill your plants.
Take it from me ‐‐ I know.
I used to be
a plant serial killer.
So I set out to design a product
for people like me,
who love to be around nature,
but who just aren't very good
at the nurture part.
The Edn wall garden
is an intelligent indoor garden
that takes the guesswork
out of growing
and ensures perfect results.
Our software
automates everything.
We control the lighting,
the watering,
and the plant food,
so you can have fresh herbs,
vegetables, and even flowers
all year round
right in the comfort
of your own home.
Our app guides you
through the entire process.
There's no dirt, so you just
add water, plant food,
drop in your seed pods,
and our technology
takes care of the rest.
The wall garden's designed
to be an engaging experience
that breathes life
into your home
and makes gardening fun again
for the entire family.
I'd like to hand out
some samples of our seed pods
and then dive
into some questions.
Okay.
So, I got you each
a seed pod.
All right.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Greiner: Thank you.
Appreciate that.
Thank you, Kevin.
Anything for you,
Robert.
‐Thank you, sir.
‐Not a problem.
So, Ryan,
do I have to use your pods,
or can I just
put my own seeds
into this little
plastic thing again?
Yeah, so our goal is to have
a great user experience,
so you can use our pods.
They're gonna be delivered.
It's extremely simple
to operate,
but if you want to plant
your own seeds, you can.
How would you say you're
different from AeroGardens?
So, for one, we have
an absolutely beautiful design,
but we also have
intelligence.
So the idea is that
while this is operating,
we can perfect the growth
of different types of plants.
So, that's kind of the power
of the Edn operating system.
And how much
does it cost?
So, the cost is $499
for the large unit,
and then the small unit
is $99,
which I call that
the gateway garden.
How much
do the pods cost, Ryan?
The pods ‐‐
so $12 subscription per month,
and we've got
an 82% margin on those.
So the subscription service
is to kind of continually
bring in new plants.
Do I have to buy
the subscription service?
You do not, no.
Do you get to choose
what your plants are?
‐You do, yes.
‐Okay.
Ryan,
do I buy this online?
Yeah, so right now,
we sell direct to consumer.
And then in the future,
when we get our prices down,
we want to go
big‐box retail.
Just this last winter,
we ran a campaign
where we did
$10,000 worth of sales
in just five days.
I was actually online
this summer
looking at
alternative products
just to grow cilantro
[chilantro]
'cause I like to have
fresh cilantro.
That's one
of my shticks.
‐Did you say "chilantro"?
‐Cilantro.
Whatever.
I ‐‐ I like it.
Cilantro.
And there was
tons and tons
of consumer,
small‐based hydroponic labs.
Right.
What you're adding to the story
is the design feel,
but I saw stuff
as cheap as 40 bucks.
I think what differentiates us
is the design, of course,
but then also the technology.
The name Edn actually stands for
"Environmental Data Network."
And the vision of Edn
is to perfect the growth
of any type of plant.
Ryan, you need somebody
on this journey
that enjoys plants and shares
in this passion with you.
Yeah.
It's just not my thing.
I'm out.
Well, I appreciate it,
nonetheless.
‐Yep.
‐Thank you.
Ryan, I'm in the same ballpark
as Robert.
I tried to grow a cactus,
and it lasted about a day.
It's just ‐‐ it's not an area
I have a feel for, so I'm out.
Really appreciate it, Mark.
Thank you.
Thank you, Ryan.
This becomes
so technological.
I worry if it takes a lot
of the soul out of the process,
and I ‐‐ that's a weird thing
to hear from the technology guy.
One of the first things I say
is "Where's your app?
What's your
app strategy?"
Right.
And this is one
of those companies
where I ask,
"Why the app?"
Right.
I actually don't think
it's that necessary.
Right.
I think there's
a niche business
for people who are
geeking out over the data,
but I don't think that's
that's gonna help you sell
hundreds of thousands
of these.
I'm out.
Appreciate it, Chris.
I'll tell you where
I'm at with it, Ryan.
Um, I'm intrigued.
I can help you
get this into retail ‐‐
the Bed Bath & Beyond,
the Target, the Walmarts,
but this price point isn't
gonna work for those guys.
It's gonna have to be
a different price point.
Maybe a more
dumbed‐down product.
I'll do the deal
$150,000 for 15%.
You know, I understand it's more
than you wanted to give up...
Wow.
...but I'm so valuable
it's ridiculous.
That's shocking.
That's actually
a really good offer.
Yeah.
What is the light
doing to you?
No, I just ‐‐ I think it's ‐‐
I'm intrigued, I'm intrigued.
And I can definitely help you
in distribution.
Well, Ryan ‐‐
Greiner:
I have another question.
I never get to grow things.
I'm always traveling.
Woltz: Right.
So if you said that I could
be gone for weeks at a time
and that the light would stay on
and it would stay watered
and I wouldn't come home
and everything's dead,
because of your technology,
because of my app.
Right.
Is that the case?
Yeah,
so that's the case.
It's made for people who travel,
people who ‐‐
Ryan, I don't want
to listen to Lori anymore.
So what if I'm gone
for a month?
I made you an offer.
You have
to make a decision.
I'll do the deal
I just gave you.
Herjavec: Ooh.
Well, let me ‐‐ let me
just finish.
I don't want to li‐‐
I don't want to compete.
I want to hear.
And I'll tell you
what's gonna happen.
If she drops out,
it's going up to 25%.
I'm gonna
make you an offer,
but I'm gonna do
a conditional offer.
‐Okay.
‐Okay?
$150,000 for 25%.
[ Laughs ]
But I'm gonna
tell you why.
Because I think ‐‐
No, no, I'm now at 25%.
That's official.
‐Ryan, Ryan, Ryan.
‐It's beautiful ‐‐ wait.
There's an offer of 15% ‐‐
Not anymore.
Wait, wait.
It's beautiful ‐‐
Lori poisoned your deal.
The reason why is because I need
to take over manufacturing...
Okay.
...so that you can get
this cost way down.
Because you want
to blow these out.
Right.
You want these
in every home.
Right.
You want people
to be able to afford it.
Right.
And at $500,
it's not affordable.
But I think we could probably
get it slashed in half.
Isn't that
what you said, Kevin?
And that's
what's important.
That's exactly
what I said.
Ryan, you know what I think
the most important thing is ‐‐
getting a deal!
Yes, hey, I ‐‐ I agree.
I just want
to hear everybody out.
Greiner: It is important
getting a deal.
And just so we're clear, Ryan,
I have no contingencies.
Of course
I want the price down.
I will help you there,
but it's not a contingency.
So, Kevin ‐‐
My offer
is $150,000 for 25%.
Unfortunately, I had
to pay a terrible price
on listening to her.
Ooh.
So we have the same offer,
essentially, on the table.
Without a contingency,
in my case.
But I think my contingency's
a good one.
I don't think so.
Why take risks?
It's only gonna help you.
So I guess my question is,
Kevin, do you have experience
with manufacturing?
‐Yes.
‐Kevin does not.
Yes, I do!
Okay, so you know I've done
over 600 products.
We all
manufacture overseas.
I would say
35% of my portfolio ‐‐
Do you know who has
the number‐one
electronic‐component product
out of "Shark Tank"
right now?
It's called IllumiBowl,
it's manufactured in China.
Oh, my God.
He's so ridiculous.
Number two,
I make more Christmas lights
than anybody else
in China.
Kevin, are you willing
to go down back to 15%?
No way.
If you're willing to go back,
I'll make a deal now.
[ Scoffs ] Kevin.
Why didn't you take the deal
when you had it?
Because, you know, I wanted ‐‐
I wanted to hear Lori out.
O'Leary: I work with a lot
of entrepreneurs.
Yeah.
You've got to bond right away.
Bird‐in‐hand theory.
I think you have
to make a decision
between the two of us.
Kevin,
I'm willing to go with you
if you can drop down
to 20%.
No.
I'm out.
‐Oh.
‐Lesson learned.
All right. Well, I, you know,
very much appreciate it,
but for the vision that I want
to create for this company,
I know it's gonna require
additional capital.
And so to get there,
it just doesn't make sense to me
right now
from a valuation standpoint.
Good for you, Ryan.
That's an expensive
walk down the hallway.
Ryan, the lesson here
is when you get an offer
that you're willing to take,
take it.
You didn't close.
‐Thank you.
Hey, appreciate it.
Thank y'all so much
for your time.
Good luck.
If I could turn back the clock,
I would have accepted his deal,
but, you know, I can't do that,
and he stuck with it.
You know, I respect that,
and, you know, lesson learned.
Well, you taught that young man
a valuable lesson.
Let that be a lesson, Robert.
Don't mess with me.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is an innovation
in the travel industry.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Yannis Moati.
I'm the CEO
of Hotels by Day.
And I'm Brian Dass,
CTO of Hotels by Day.
We're here today
seeking $750,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
Sharks, our company is
reinventing the hotel stay.
How many times have you
or someone you know
traveled to a city
just for the day?
You get into the city
at 8:00 A. M.,
and you have a meeting
at 1:00 P. M.
What do you do
with those hours in between?
There is a massive gap
in the market,
and that is why we've created
Hotels by Day.
Jimmy...
Together: Roll the tape!
Hotels by Day,
through our app and our website,
allows customers
to book a day room.
You arrive early at your hotel,
you check in early,
you relax in your room,
you order some room service,
refresh, own your meeting,
and close the sale.
Our model is a paradigm shift
in the hospitality industry.
It generates revenue
for hotels.
It gives guests
flexibility.
And it closes the loop
on the customer journey.
So, Sharks, who's ready to check
in early with Hotels by Day?
Why does it feel like
a "Saturday Night Live" skit?
[ Laughter ]
How does it work?
Tell me the pricing.
So, on average,
it's six hours
that are being provided
by the hotel at $90.
O'Leary: I have one question
that could settle this
in either a great way
or it could end badly
right here.
Please, go ahead.
Why in the world
wouldn't all the other sites
that already exist in a really
cluttered, competitive space
simply add this feature?
Sure.
Well,
technology right now
doesn't allow any of the majors
to go into the space.
Herjavec:
Yannis, hang on a sec.
There's
a technical reason
why the other people
can't offer this
on a block‐hour rate?
Yeah.
I'm dying to hear this.
Why?
Most hotel‐property‐management
systems
cannot handle
a day‐room booking.
‐It does not work like that.
‐Let me ask you a question.
But they charge late‐check‐in
rates all the time,
unless you're able
to negotiate out of it.
Let's use a chain name ‐‐
a Marriott ‐‐
I say, "Look, I'm not
checking in until 4:00."
"I'm sorry, there's
an extra $80 charge there."
You just mentioned that
there's an analogue process ‐‐
you calling the hotel,
you e‐mailing the hotel.
Sacca: Before we
move on, just ‐‐
So how have you solved
that technology problem
with your own
outside technology?
Dass:
We're actually connecting
to what is called
a channel‐management system
that actually connects
to the availability, rates,
and inventory.
So there is a way that we're
connecting to get the rates
to be able to set the rates up
to the half‐a‐day room.
Cuban: So how are
you blocking out ‐‐
Wait, how ‐‐
Can I step back?
It doesn't ‐‐ wait.
The central reservation system
does not take in day bookings.
It's 30‐year‐old
technology.
Any booking that goes
into the CRS,
the central
reservation system,
is factored in
as a night stay.
‐No, I accept that.
‐So wait.
You're not doing a ‐‐
so, look,
you're not doing a great job
of explaining it.
If their internal technology
can't do it,
how does your
external technology...
All right.
...fix or supplant
or override or bypass
their internal
technology?
Chris.
Let me tell you.
We are taking a fraction
of their inventory
that is sitting empty
between 9:00 and 6:00,
and we are selling it
to the customers.
With the workaround technology
that Brian has created ‐‐
Well, what is
that techno‐‐
Like, is it actual technology
or is just a hack?
Yes, it's technology ‐‐
I'll tell you why ‐‐
because we're connecting
to a channel manager.
So instead of going
through the CRS,
we're connecting
to a channel manager,
going straight
into the hotel.
And that is something that
we are provisionally patented.
Herjavec: How can that
be proprietary?
Let's say Kevin's
one of the other travel sites.
He hires a CTO
that can develop any ‐‐
He didn't write
the software.
Anyone can duplicate
technology.
It's not a barrier drain.
It's a hack.
It's just
the first‐to‐market advantage.
Right.
How many hours
have you rented?
What's your margin?
How many customers do you have?
Et cetera, et cetera?
We are at 6,500 bookings.
All of the year of 2015,
we generated about $127,000
in gross booking revenue,
of which we're taking 14%,
all right?
That's all?
That's our cut, yes.
It's low.
Wow.
But it's ‐‐
But it's reasonable.
It's a starting point.
Do you have a deal
with big hotel chains?
Yes.
We have signed every single
brand out there individually ‐‐
300 properties.
But get back to ‐‐ why don't
the big guys crush you
like the cockroaches
you are?
As I said before,
they cannot connect right now.
They will not
waste their time.
Kevin,
they'll be wasting more time
to try to connect
to a CRS that does not work.
What you're doing is
you're selling
somebody else's product,
and you're telling us
they're incapable of selling it
and that you have
some hack to get to it.
But you've done a really
poor job of explaining
why that hack is so hard to make
or why it's defensible
or why it's proprietary
to you at all.
Well ‐‐
And so don't be shocked
that there's a lot of doubt
on this side of the room.
First of all, the hotel
can't sell day rooms.
They have not created
a system behind it.
And two, the technology
and the protocol,
they are missing.
It takes time,
it takes investment.
Guys, I do think it's a problem
you're trying to solve.
That said, every time
I tried to ask you
what technological, defensible,
proprietary approach
do you have here,
I couldn't get a straight answer
back from you guys.
I don't actually think
there is something there.
But we've also filed
several patents.
It feels like
a cobbled‐together hack, like ‐‐
No,
but before you go on ‐‐
But, sure, go ahead.
We've had conversations
at the majors.
They think it's really
interesting what ‐‐
They think it's
really interesting,
but those conversations
haven't ended up in a sale
'cause you don't have
anything to buy.
Your competition isn't
the big hotel chains.
It's the software layer that
already rides on top of that.
If you came in here
and told me
you were reinventing
the entire management system
the way OpenTable reinvented
the booking platform
for a restaurant,
I'd be interested,
but you're not.
The quickest way to double
your money in this deal
is to fold it over,
put it in your back pocket.
I'm out.
Ouch.
Herjavec: Wow.
Just so you know,
up to last May,
we've generated $300,000,
so the model is accelerating
20% month‐to‐month growth.
Yeah, because you're working
with tiny numbers, though ‐‐
that's why.
The challenge is
how big can it be.
Just to give you
an idea,
we've seen how many people
log into our site from New York
that converts into a day stay
in New York ‐‐ it's 8%.
If we were to run 8%
throughout the top cities
of visitors
into our website,
we'll be already
at 12,000 bookings.
Let's say you do that,
right?
You get
the 12,000 bookings.
Yeah, easy.
Easy.
That's $200,000
gross revenue.
That's $28,000 a month.
That's not enough.
I'm out.
Well, all right.
Thank you.
Guys, it's a great idea.
Mm‐hmm, thank you.
I do this all the time
when I travel.
I show up
at 8:00 in the morning.
We always have to book
two nights of hotel rooms.
There's no question
that there is a market there.
But I just think that
you're a proof of concept
for one
of the bigger players.
If you prove the market,
they'll do it.
There's nothing proprietary
that you have.
I'm out.
Uh, thank you,
Robert.
Thank you.
I‐I'd like
to reassure you
that the majors
won't play this game.
They cannot
get into it.
Never build the strategy
on the stupidity
of your competitors.
If there's a market there,
and you prove the market...
No, that is not
the strategy.
...they're gonna do it.
The strategy
is for us to grow it.
Either way, I'm out.
Mark's out.
Chris is out.
Kevin and Lori are still in.
Well, let me tell you
what I think.
I see your product
as like a big puzzle.
And there's so many missing
pieces for me that I'm out.
If I thought that there was
a cockroach strategy ‐‐
and there's nothing wrong
with being a roach,
be the best roach
you can be ‐‐
at the end of the day,
if you can survive
because nobody else wants
your tiny market, that's great.
It's true.
But that's not
what you said.
$750,000 ‐‐
if you had made this
maybe $150,000, $250,000,
I'd ride with the roaches
for a while, figure it out.
I like the space actually,
but I can't do that.
You've made it impossible
to invest.
I'm out.
Thank you, Kevin.
Thank you so much
for your time.
Dass: Thank you.
Thank you.
‐Good luck.
‐Thanks, bye.
Thanks.
Sacca: There's nothing
more frustrating
than asking questions
about somebody's tech stack
and not getting
any answers back.
Moati: The Sharks did not see
the opportunity today.
They gave us
absolutely no time
nor a chance to explain
how we do business,
and that was a shame.
Shame on them.
Many hotels do it now.
Their whole point is
they simplify that process.
But they automate that.
Yeah.
Look ‐‐ it's a problem
that needs to be solved,
the hotels would like
to make the extra money.
They didn't do anything
to convince us
that they're
the guys to do it.
And they're
cockroaches.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a company
hoping to spark the curiosity
of our future generations.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Scott Lininger.
And I'm Aidan Chopra,
and we are from
beautiful Boulder, Colorado.
Our company is Bitsbox,
and we are here today
seeking $250,000
for 3% of our company.
Herjavec: Whew.
Bitsbox is the world's
most creative way
to teach kids a skill that will
change their lives forever ‐‐
computer coding.
These days,
it's not enough
for kids to just know
how to use computers.
They need to know
the language of computers,
and that language
is called "coding."
Coding is a golden ticket to
a great job and a great future.
And the best thing
is that anybody can learn.
The hard part
about teaching kids to code
isn't getting them interested,
it's keeping them interested.
That's why
Bitsbox is a present
that comes in the mail
every month.
It's a subscription box
that teaches
real computer programming.
So, we wanted to show you
how it works.
So, what we did is invite one of
our very favorite Bitsbox‐ers ‐‐
Grace, over there ‐‐
to help us.
Now, Grace's box
just came in the mail,
and she's super excited.
It just so happens
that this month,
there is a "Shark Tank" app
in the box.
She goes to the Bitsbox website
she goes into her account,
she starts
a brand‐new app,
and she starts
to type in the code
exactly as it appears
on the card.
Now, here's the thing ‐‐
code is just
a set of instructions
that tells a computer
what to do.
So, if we actually look
at the code that she's typed,
you can see line one
tells the computer
to fill the screen
with an image of a shark tank.
Line two tells it to stamp an
image of a shark on the screen,
and line three says, "Hey,
when somebody taps that shark,
I want you
to make the shark pop."
The Bitsbox approach
is to give the kids
lots of example projects,
just like this one,
that they can build upon.
And eventually, you start making
your own stuff from scratch.
Now, Grace is pretty advanced,
so she's already gone
and created the rest
of the challenges in this app.
Herjavec: Whoa.
And you can see,
she's made a full video game
with animations
and sound effects.
‐Oh.
"Mark wins?"
I'm out.
Cuban: Good, Grace.
[ Laughs ]
So, Sharks, who wants
to help us change the world?
Grace, how old are you?
10.
Were you coding
before you did this?
Yes. I was coding Python
and some C++ before this.
[ Chuckles ]
I mean, that's awesome.
What do you want to be
when you grow up?
I want to be
a bionic‐limb programmer.
A bionic‐limb programmer,
huh?
What?!
‐Good for you, Grace.
‐That's amazing.
Well, what makes you
want to do that?
Yeah.
Well, 'cause I really loved
anatomy when I was little,
and I actually told
my neighbor one time ‐‐
I brought out
my book of diseases to him
and I said, "What's your
favorite disease?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said,
"Mine's tapeworm."
[ Laughter ]
We had that same conversation
at lunch with Kevin.
Yeah.
All right,
tell us about the business.
You bet. So, Bitsbox ranges
in monthly subscriptions
from $20 to $40 a month,
depending on the options
that you choose.
How long do I have
to sign up for?
It's up to you.
You can start up
month‐to‐month
and cancel at any time,
or you can sign up
for a full year in advance.
What do I get
for that price difference?
The $40 level
is the full box.
It has a set of app cards
every month.
You get a toy
that matches the theme,
such as a whoopee cushion
with code on it.
Anything else we can think of
to keep the kids excited.
What is the ages for this?
Somewhere between
6 and 14.
Cuban: What does a box
cost you to make?
About $10.
But that's at printing very,
very small quantities of paper.
It gets much cheaper
at scale.
How long
have you been doing this,
and what
have your sales been?
We launched the product
less than two years ago.
Wow.
Since then, we've done
$1.3 million in revenue.
Are you making
any money yet?
We're not
cash‐flow positive yet
because we have a team
of five full‐time people.
But we are on the road
to be cash‐flow positive
this upcoming quarter.
What's your background?
Aidan and I met ‐‐
we worked at the world's largest
Internet company, Google.
Scott built this as a prototype
for his daughter when she was 7.
She loved it, and a few other
kids loved it, as well.
He decided
he was gonna quit, and ‐‐
you want
to re‐create it?
Yeah.
[ Inspiring music plays ]
Aidan, let's quit.
Let's go teach
the world's children to code.
You had me
at "Let's quit."
We actually did that.
[ Laughter ]
We did that because,
at the time, you know ‐‐
it was pretty good.
Herjavec:
That was really good!
And did you go out
and raise money
after that romantic...?
Yeah. So, we did a seed round
last summer for $500,000
on a $4 million
pre‐money valuation.
$250,000 at 3% imputes
an $8 million value.
Mm‐hmm.
Why would you
raise the price
by a factor of seven
for a Shark?
Is that
a sign of disrespect?
No, no, not at all.
We looked at
all of our revenue to date,
and we took
a 10‐x multiple on that.
We'd done about $400,000
in revenue.
How much of that
is left in the bank right now?
We raised a bridge note
last spring...
‐How much?
‐Oh, oh.
...for $600,000.
‐Oh.
Chopra:
It's a convertible note
at a $6 million cap.
You did a great job
of selling yourselves.
This is a great
and very valuable product.
I'm gonna clear the field
to my fellow Sharks,
who have more experience in the
subscription business than I do.
So, I'm out.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, Lori.
O'Leary: What you're doing
is important because
we're only graduating 50,000
engineers a year in America,
and the Chinese are
graduating 260,000.
Wow.
We're losing the race.
So, this is very useful.
I'm glad you get it.
So, I'm going to applaud
watching Cuban and Sacca
beat the living you‐know‐what
out of each other
to get a piece
of this deal.
I'm out.
I don't know.
I didn't hear anything
from Robert.
You've done an amazing job.
I know this space.
Make an offer.
I'm not gonna
make an offer,
'cause I think
there's a lot of competition,
and I don't want
to be in this space.
I'm out.
‐Okay. Thanks.
‐Thank you.
Well, then, Mark Cuban,
Chris Sacca.
Guys, I'm gonna make it
easier on Chris.
I love what
you're doing, right?
I think the goal is phenomenal,
all right?
I think you've made
great progress.
But I think, to get it to scale
to any meaningful level,
I think it's gonna
be very difficult
and become
more expensive,
and you're gonna have
to raise much more money.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thanks.
Greiner:
And then there was one.
Hey, guys.
‐Chris.
‐Hey.
I love
being in this position.
We're Googlers,
you're a Googler.
[ Laughs ]
Feel free to be a savage
on equity, Sacca.
Look, I'm intrigued.
It's a company I can believe in.
Such an important
subject matter
to the kids of America
and beyond.
Yes.
And so,
I'm gonna make you an offer.
Sure.
I'm gonna give you
your 250K
at a $5 million valuation.
We do have many,
many other investors,
and I think
we want to do right by them
by making
the right decision.
But none of them
are Sharks.
No, we completely
understand that.
But I think what we want
to understand is,
dilution is a real thing,
and I think we're trying
to do the right thing by them,
as well.
I need to own
enough of your company
for me to get
really thrilled about it,
to throw everything I have
into it, and to go for it.
So, you asked
for an $8 million valuation.
Mr. Sacca's brought it way down
to $5 million.
‐He sure has.
‐What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna hit
Enter or Delete?
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Chris has made an offer
for Scott and Aidan's
children's‐coding
education company, Bitsbox.
But it is well below
their initial valuation.
So, you asked
for an $8 million valuation.
Mr. Sacca's brought it way down
to $5 million.
‐He sure has.
‐What are you gonna do?
Are you gonna hit
Enter or Delete?
So, Chris,
we think you're amazing.
No offense to any
of the other Sharks,
but you were the guy that
we would absolutely love
to have in the deal.
Good sucking up.
What about a valuation
of $7 million?
Ooh, all that niceness,
and then ‐‐ boom.
Look, I'm very confident about
the value I bring to your deal.
I mean,
you guys moved 0.57% off
where you were
when you came in here.
Sure.
I see an inconsistency
in your statements ‐‐
between all this love
you're showing me
and then the numbers
you came back with.
Ugh.
I don't even want
to come back.
Let me see
that piece of paper.
Sure.
Yeah.
Would you do 4%?
That's the valuation,
is 6 1/4 ‐‐
$6.25 million.
Your last investors came in
at a $6 million cap.
Are we seriously
nickle‐and‐diming over $250,000?
I mean ‐‐
‐Wow.
You're that close, and you're
gonna show me the disrespect?
O'Leary:
Give him the $6 million.
[ Sighs ]
I'll tell you what ‐‐
I'll tell you what,
I'm gonna make it
easy on you.
I know what I bring
to the table.
And this is a long,
long road ahead,
and you've got the ruler out
and you're measuring
in quarters of inches right now.
You're not looking
at the magnitude of value
I can bring down the road.
And so, I'm gonna make it
easy on you ‐‐ I'm out.
‐Oh, oh.
‐Ouch.
‐Ooh.
‐Whoa.
The better way
to understand it is,
he wanted $5 million,
you wanted $8 million.
It seemed that you could've
agreed at $6 million,
you nickle‐and‐dimed him
for $6.25 million,
which, obviously,
he's not happy with.
Right.
If you did the deal
at $6 million,
maybe you could
get him back in.
I don't know.
Chris, what if
we did $6 million?
I know that you feel offended,
but you have to understand ‐‐
this isn't malevolence,
it's ineptitude.
[ Laughter ]
We would love
to work with you.
It sends a message to me, you're
not focused on the bigger prize.
You're thinking about
some of the tiny, little
nit‐picks along the way.
You're losing him!
You know what,
I'm gonna jump in here
and say that
we would love to do...
What are we doing?
Can we do 4.75%?
Oh, my gosh,
why not just do the 5%?!
I'm sorry.
Let's sort of reset this.
And we completely agree that
having you on the Bitsbox team
would be worth
5% of equity to us.
So, with the benefit
of time and humility
and a certain amount
of humiliation,
uh, what do you think,
Scott?
[ Sighs ]
I mean, look, guys,
here's the thing...
W‐Wow.
...three, four decimal places
matter a lot
when you're trying to put
a rocket on the moon.
Mm‐hmm.
But in the early days
of your business,
when you're putting together
your founding teams,
your investors and users...
Yeah.
...it just shows me
your priorities and your focus
might be
in the wrong place,
that you're nitpicking
over that stuff
that really doesn't matter
a hill of beans in the end.
What do you think,
Scott?
[ Exhales sharply ]
Good luck to you guys.
I'm out.
Should we do it?
Should we do $5 million?
He's out!
Greiner: No, you guys.
He's out.
It's over.
Yeah. Y‐You've hesitated
so many times.
And by the way,
I'm hiring Grace.
Oh, it's over?
We're done?
‐Yeah.
‐It's over.
There's no more to go?
It's over
for the third time.
Lininger: Okay, yeah.
Well, thank you very much,
Chris.
[ Scattered groans ]
I don't think we've ever lost
a deal on "Shark Tank" for .25%.
Thank you, everybody.
Okay.
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Thanks very much.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you, Grace.
Thank you for your time.
She's so polite.
Cuban:
For .25%, they let it
slip between their fingers.
Bozos.
I think
you're pretty good.
Yeah.
You're doing pretty good
on your own.
I think we did okay.
You don't need
some famous person
with a lot of money
just to...
[ Laughs ]
...to keep going
with the business, you know?
That's right.
I like your attitude.
‐Yeah.
‐Thank you.
Thanks, Grace.
You made me feel better.
‐Yeah.
‐Cool.